Tomar creatina sem atividade física
regular compensa ou é jogar dinheiro
fora? Olha só, vou te contar uma
história que aconteceu no consultório
semana passada. Um paciente chegou para
mim segurando o pote de creatina e
perguntou: "Doutor, meu amigo da
academia disse que isso aqui é bom, mas
eu nem malho direito. Tô jogando
dinheiro fora? Sabe que essa pergunta
aparece direto? E a resposta não é um
simples sim ou não. É bem mais
interessante do que parece. Vamos
começar do básico, porque muita gente
ainda acha que creatina é algum tipo de
anabolizante ou coisa do tipo. Nada
disso. A creatina é uma substância super
natural que o seu próprio corpo produz.
Imagina só, seu fígado, rins e pâncreas
trabalham juntinhos produzindo cerca de
1 a 2 g por dia. É tipo uma fábrica
interna de energia que nunca para. E
olha que legal, você também pega a
creatina quando você come aquele bifão
suculento ou um peixe grelhado.
Carne vermelha tem uns 2 g dessa
belezinha. Agora vem a parte que muita
gente não sabe. Cerca de 95% da creatina
fica guardada nos músculos. Mas e os
outros 5%? Ah, esses ficam no cérebro,
coração, outros órgãos importantes. É
como se fosse uma bateria reserva
espalhada pelo corpo todo. E é aqui que
a conversa começa a ficar interessante
para quem não frequenta a academia. Sabe
quando você tá naquele final de dia, a
cabeça pesando, ainda tem que estudar
pro concurso ou terminar aquele
relatório chato do trabalho? Pois é,
estudos recentes mostram que a creatina
pode dar aquela força paraa sua massa
cinzenta. Também uma pesquisa publicada
em 2024 na Scientific Reports descobriu
que uma única dose creatina pode
melhorar o desempenho cognitivo quando
você tá cansado. É como se desse um
boost num processador do seu cérebro,
entendeu? E não para por aí. Tem gente
estudando como a creatina pode ajudar na
memória de curto prazo, no raciocínio
rápido e até na qualidade do sono. Um
estudo com idosos sedentários, ou seja,
galera que nem pensava em academia,
mostrou melhora na memória dentro de
seis semanas tomando creatina. Bacana,
não é? Mas vamos falar do elefante na
sala e o músculo. Bom, aí que tá sem
exercício, pode esquecer aquele shape
dos sonhos. A creatina sozinha não faz
milagre. Aqui pode acontecer que você
ganha 1 ou 2 kg por causa da retenção de
água nos músculos. É tipo uma esponja
que enche um pouquinho. Mas músculo de
verdade, definição força, só com o
estímulo do treino mesmo, meu caro.
Agora tem um lado bem interessante que a
medicina funcional vem explorando. A
creatina tem mostrato do potencial
neuroprotetor, palavrão bonito para
dizer que ela protege neurônios. Alguns
estudos sugerem que pode ajudar na
prevenção de doenças como Paxon e
Alzheimer. É como se fosse um capacete
invisível pro seu cérebro, protegendo
contra o desgaste do tempo. E olha que
curioso, pesquisas preliminares indicam
que a creatina pode até melhorar a
sensibilidade insulina. Traduzindo, pode
ajudar o seu corpo a usar melhor o
açúcar do sangue. Mas calma lá, não é
para sair tomando creatina achando que
vai curar diabetes, ok? São estudos
iniciais ainda. Então, respondendo
aquela pergunta do meu paciente, depende
do que você espera. Se a ideia é ficar
bombado sem suar a camisa, pode guardar
o dinheiro. Mas se você quer dar uma
turbinada na função cerebral, melhorar a
memória, ter mais energia pro dia a dia,
ainda proteger os seus neurônios, aí a
conversa muda de figura. É como investir
numa pólice segura pro cérebro. Você não
vê resultado imediato, mas lá na frente
pode fazer toda a diferença. A dose
geralmente são 3 a 5 g por dia nessa
faixa. E sempre procure creatina de
qualidade com selo creapura de
preferência que garante a pureza. Ah, e
não esquece beber água, viu? A creatina
puxa água pros músculos. Então, se você
não se hidratar direito, pode acabar com
dor de cabeça.
No fim das contas, cada caso é um caso.
Para quem tem uma dieta rica em proteína
animal, talvez nem precise suplementar.
Mas veganos, vegetarianos, idosos ou
quem quer aquele plus na função
cognitiva podem se beneficiar bastante.
É questão de alinhar expectativa e
realidade. A creatina não é pílula
mágica, mas também não é jogar dinheiro
fora. É mais como investimento
estratégico na sua saúde global,
especialmente na saúde do seu cérebro. E
convenhamos, no mundo onde a gente
precisa estar cada vez mais ligado,
qualquer ajudinha paraa massa cinzenta,
bem-vindo, né? Yeah.